thrilled to be able to call this man a
friend and when uh a friend has got a
new app
to try and hook you up and hook coaches
up
in the youth sports world with
an ability to develop practices at the
touch of a button in seconds and that
app is called mojo
and he is available to talk on this show
and
i can help support what a friend is up
to i'm all for it
and the former president of disney abc
television group and abc news and now
the founder and ceo of mojo
ben sherwood here on the rich housing
show how you been ben
hey rich thanks for having me on look at
us talking on tv
streaming and radio look at us
as opposed to texting and emailing
actual conversation let's get into this
because obviously you know youth sports
is
roaring back uh to life like mulch like
as i'm knocking on wood right now on my
head
like the rest of the sports world and
society what what is mojo all about
what uh people can go to this app
and um and have supported in their youth
sports world
then well youth sports is roaring back
in fact this morning we were talking
with some of the folks who handle
registrations across the country
for some of the biggest sports leagues
and they say that they've never seen
numbers like this they're they're back
and they're above pre-pandemic levels
as kids are rushing back outside to play
sports
and our are we started mojo 99 days ago
launched exactly 99 days ago to help
moms and dads who are volunteering to
help coach their kids
have a better experience save time
preparing for practice
save stress because it's a stressful
experience if you've coached as you
as you know four to fourteen year olds
and have a better experience on the
field
and so far thousands of teams are using
mojo for soccer across the country and
the data is coming in we're
starting to see and hear from the
coaches and about more than 80 percent
of the moms and dads using the mojo app
to plan their soccer practices
that's our first sports soccer are
saying that they've saved time it's less
stressful
and the kids are having more fun and
we're going to be rolling out
flag football in the fall and
i thought that'd be up your alley
they're going to have basket basketball
in the winter
and then by next spring we'll have a
little league and softball sewer and
then
we'll roll in volleyball after that so
soon
any sport you're coaching your kids in
between the ages of 4 and 14
mojo will plan your practice at the
touch of a button it'll give you
most trusted resources on what
activities to do
what's age appropriate for
four-year-olds or for ten-year-olds or
for twelve-year-olds boys and girls
and we will set you up so that you can
just have fun and not worry about
when you get out of work and are rushing
to the field oh shoot what am i going to
do with these kids today
so um are you consulting
um actual coaches in these sports to
come up with what the best
practices are i mean how are you going
about this ben
rich you know me pretty well and you
know that that i love telling stories i
love making content i've done that for
30 years but you know that i have a lot
of humility about sports so we are
working with the world's top experts in
each of our sports
our partner in soccer is us youth soccer
the biggest soccer league in the united
states with 3 million kids and about 300
000 coaches
and we've been working with the top
experts to develop our activities
activities that are proven for every age
group we're working now with fc
barcelona
for a special offering that we'll be
putting out at the end of the summer
uh from their renowned la masia academy
where
level messi trained and learned to
dribble and pass and shoot and we'll be
working with them on special curriculum
so we work with the very best in every
sport
to develop the very best activities for
kids from 4 to 14.
this is for this is for the 99 of
families rich
whose kids are probably not going to
play d1 they're probably not going to go
pro they're not going to the olympics
this is for
really kind of the grassroots the wreck
all the families out there
that just want to go outside and have a
great time with their kids and make
memories for a lifetime
that's what mojo is for that's why we
called it mojo we want to bring the
magic back to youth sports because as
you know it's gotten very
professionalized it's gotten very
competitive
it's gotten very elite this is this is
really to help moms and dads everywhere
i have a great experience and i'm proud
to say that just just yesterday
mojo received the webby award
for the best the best sports app of 2021
98 days after we launched uh recognition
is the best of the internet in fact the
president of the webbies
uh said about mojo we caught them by
surprise
uh about that we represent in terms of
creativity and innovation the best of
the internet and so we're really proud
of that it's a sort of validation for
what we're trying to do which is give
families great trusted resources
to have a great time in sports well ben
sherwood you also know from your tv days
that you got to drop some names
so uh russell wilson how did you get him
involved
in this is he is he going to be your
flag football
guy and is he going to suddenly demand
more protection for the quarterbacks
in in your in your coaching schemes and
things like that is that
the way this is going to go ben has this
work so
russell believe it or not yes is
an assistant little league coach in san
diego and
we were introduced and he heard about
what we're trying to do which is we're
trying to make the experience better for
moms and dads we're coaching and
remember
you know better than anyone russ was was
drafted into major league baseball he
knows that game really well too
and he has suffered on the sidelines
coaching his son
and he feels like there is a need in the
world
for a trusted resource to help moms and
dads
get through a season of little league
without doing any harm and making sure
everybody has a good time and so he
joined us not just as an investor
but he came on board as a board member
uh
and an advisor and he's encouraged us as
the chairman of nfl flag he's encouraged
us to do flag football
okay and so yes he will be you will be
giving us help but i think he will have
a special interest in quarterback
protection
ben hold on a second he's an assistant
coach he's not running the team he's
just
like the guy who's just support staff is
he like running the uh
the the snack the post-game snacks like
like russell's bringing
the snacks not only is he the assistant
yes but believe it or not the head coach
wouldn't even give him a hat
so he had to go get the hat separately
because they didn't have enough hats for
the coaches which by the way that
happens
every every parent in youth sports knows
that
usually the assistant doesn't get
anything yeah and so he had to go out
and get his own hat so that he kind of
fit it on the sidelines coaching at
third base
oh my gosh well this is amazing ben um
so how so this is where all apps are
required right app store just go and
look for mojo mojo and and
and because you know so many parents you
know i have as
we've discussed this i have you know
coached a team susie's coached a team my
wife's coached a team and
you know uh we want to make sure that
everyone's having fun that is that was
always my rule my rule was have fun and
respect the opponent those are my two
rules
um and and but you also want to make
sure that you're teaching the kids what
they need to know fundamentally that
there is
some form of coaching that does need to
be required and i was wondering if i was
doing the right thing so this app can
actually support
somebody who's in a position like that
is what you're saying the whole idea is
to take any mom or dad
with any level of experience maybe you
played in high school maybe you even
played in college or maybe you've never
played the sport you just love
watching it you want your kids to get
exposed to it right they can walk out
onto a field tonight
they can watch a few high quality videos
that we made in partnership with
mandalay sports the guys who made the
last dance about michael jordan
we there's high quality short videos
that you watch that kind of explain
the drill or the activity that tell you
what to look for
there's a whole bunch of great articles
there too that are
basically guide you on how to coach the
child first
and then the sport so that's the whole
philosophy which is that at this stage
at the different age groups you're
really trying to kind of help a kid
reach their potential you're not really
trying to
turn them into a pro ball player yet and
then
and then it just sort of basically takes
you through an entire season and then it
learns from you
about how that practice went it plans
your next practice with your next
activities you can get you get to tell
it whether or not you liked
those activities whether the kids like
the activities and then we learn from
you about what you need and then you can
even
sort of choose your own journey hey you
know what we didn't score any goals in
the last game we need to do we need to
work on our offense
we've got practices that are just about
offense for for every age group or
hey if they scored 40 goals against you
and you really need some help
you've got everything you need on
defense i think ultimately like you and
susie coached
i know that on your desk you have a best
dad ever hand plate
and i know that we all we all want to be
better parents
i think ultimately what we're really
trying to do is we're trying to help
moms and dads everywhere
have a better experience out there have
more fun
and create less friction with your kids
create less tension with your kids
and and basically make it easier for you
to do this
and make it easier for you and more fun
for your kids so that you're inclined
to do it again next season and then hey
maybe if you had so much success in
soccer
you think i'll do basketball this winter
and and this app made it so much easier
for me it took all the planning and all
the work right out of it
i can do that and hey you know what
little league's coming in the spring i
might even try that even though i've
never done anything in baseball before
we we take all that work right out of it
for you and it's just sort of
you just get to have fun on the field
that's the whole vision for the for the
for what we're doing
so uh last one for you ben sherwood uh
founder ceo of mojo
um this phenomenal app that uh helps
people
coach up kids and figure out what sort
of coach plan can be
used to develop a practice for you and
the youths that you're
you're coaching uh is there uh a portion
of mojo to deal with the a-hole parents
that think that you're preventing their
children
from getting that d1 scholarship in a
major league career and thus
essentially their retirement fund um is
there is there
is there part of the app for that
so so yes there is a uh
there is an article that that is
actually one of the most popular
articles in the app and it is one of the
most popular articles from mojo on the
web
it is called sorry your kid's not going
pro
that article lays out in exacting detail
how young serena or young ronaldo
is not going to end up at d1 and that
the statistics the probabilities of this
kid
by the way who's five and is running the
bases backward whose name is maze
that kid running the bases backward is
not gonna end up playing for the the san
francisco giants
and everybody needs to relax there is a
there's actually a syndrome
which is distortion by proxy uh which
psychologists talk about which is the
distortion that a lot of these parents
experience out there which is that they
are living their lives through their
kids
they're planning their retirement in
fact their studies from td ameritrade
that say that
that a crazy number of american families
are spending more on youth sports than
they are
on their own retirement because they
believe that their kids are going to get
scholarships and pro-contracts
and and we we we try gently to remind
people that unless you are in the 0.01
in any of these sports that's not going
to happen and it's just a lot more
important for you to have fun out there
with the kids
uh and enjoy the experience and if you
really want to have an ongoing
relationship a lasting relationship with
your kid
do not put the pressure on them that
they're supposed to go pro and just say
to them the magic words
i loved watching you play when you ride
home because the ride home
is more important than anything the ride
to the game is really important
and knowing how to handle the ride home
or the ride to the game is part of what
mojo is about we just make sure that at
the end of that journey
at the end of that youth sports journey
you're still talking to each other
because there's a whole lot more life
after youth sports
youth sports teaches all these
incredible lessons in fact as you know
sports is such an amazing teacher
but there's a huge amount of life after
they're done playing youth sports
and as a parent you want to have a
really good relationship with them
that's also where mojo comes in we're
going to try to help make that
relationship even better and not all
messed up
because you were you were coaching them
poorly you were putting all kinds of
pressure on them
and you were critiquing their batting
stance in the drive home the only words
that really work on the drive home are
i loved watching you play and i can't
wait to watch you play again i love that
message ben
there's no question i love that message
you know i love that message
but you also know that some of these
parents don't need
gentle reminders and also you ben
sherwood come
from the world of visual medium and
video will you let me take that article
and make a video version of it and let
me be the guy that delivers this message
for mojo can i do that we're sending
we're sending the crew to you right now
it's on its way articles
are like people people you know articles
whatever it's great we're reading it
maybe
you know a couple paragraphs and no no
no sometimes you got to walk through the
front door
and tell them what's what and i would
love to be that guy
please cameras on cam we're sending the
camera now
take care of yourself ben congrats on
mojo thanks a lot
you got it that's ben sherwood hey you
watched all the way to the end thanks
for that
watch more right here